there is one place where deception is
not only allowed it's rewarded the poker
table a poker player can win if they
have the best hand or if they convince
the other players that they do but even
when someone is bluffing their body
language may give them away the smallest
involuntary movements in our face are
amazingly accurate windows to our
feelings these are called micro
expressions they can last just 125th of
a second and express any one of seven
Universal emotions fear anger sadness
disgust happiness contempt and surprise
micro expressions are almost impossible
to control which is why FBI agents will
film interrogations and analyze the
footage to see if a person is lying
there are lawyers who study micro
expressions during jury selection and
psychiatrists can be trained to watch
for these small movements in therapy
sessions
if anyone can hide their micro
expressions it's people whose living
depends on it so we've invited some of
the planet's best poker players to join
us for our next game including World
Series of Poker champion and European
Tour champion Liv Boeree
hey Liv how you doing great thanks for
coming please welcome
Liv burry Egor get off
[Applause]
these poker pros make a living reading
the micro expressions on other people's
faces we're gonna see if they can keep
us from seeing theirs here's how it's
going to work for the first challenge
there are four identical shot glasses to
have apple juice to have apple cider
vinegar after each of you takes a sip
you have to say this tastes good if Ted
and I can tell who's had the juice and
who's had the vinegar we win if we can't
you win simple enough alright do it
let's get the first round underway this
tastes good
[Music]
this tastes good
this tastes good
let's taste good
jeez Louise okay all right I'm just
going straight to money we're both going
win here but but but we have another
person yeah I think it's lit because I
think she asked for the the toxic crap
and I see yeah I see now I want to say
it's Wayne and Igor so it is time to
reveal your cards who had the vinegar
raise your hand
son of a
[Applause]
okay so our next round that you can love
this guy's alright our next round is
guacamole versus wasabi so you guys
let's not let's shuffle up a taste here
we go
this tastes good okay this tastes good
wait I'm clean that was a clean win with
the chew this tastes good Oh see now
he's gonna do that every time he's gonna
make it
he's gonna say this tastes good
uncomfortably every time this stays good
oh gosh Ted this is good he is good I'm
not good but now now we know that
Wayne's got a thing he's workin baseline
on the on the vocals lives blinking like
she's so happy to be here it's bringing
her to tears yeah there might be nothing
she can do about that okay wow I got a
live in a Wayne what about you Ted I got
a E going live Egor and live chants got
Egor than live okay
time again to show your cards who had
the wasabi
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]